[Musique]
le 8 mai 1945 le 9 meur l'urss
l'allemagne nazie capitulait mettant
ainsi un terme à la seconde guerre
mondiale tout du moins sur le front
occidental
un conflit qui a semé la mort à travers
le monde et en europe tout
particulièrement et c'est l'urss qui en
a payé le plus lourd tribut avec 27
millions de morts sacrifice toujours
très présent dans la mémoire collective
du peuple russe alors que les autorités
se méfie de ce qu'elle estime être une
réécriture de l'histoire de la part de
certains gouvernements ou organisation
pour bloquer ce sujet notre avis di
natale yann laroche niscayah
universitaire historienne russe
spécialiste de cette période
est ce qu'il existe aujourd'hui une
interprétation unique univoque de cette
période de l'histoire
on a un truc denis et déjà beaucoup de
nouvelles idées pas basée sur les faits
et le document mais seulement c'est au
moment sur l'idéologie
aujourd'hui une et d un ti scientifique
que laurent a mis un moral de l'identité
de nazisme le communisme de la
culpabilité d'un de leurs essais de
l'allemagne nazie ont été avancés
devenant clichés d'une hystérie
médiatique occidentale et sont entrés
aussi dans l'arsenal politique de
plusieurs pays comme les pays bas la
pologne le crès prat
mais cette idée d'égalité de nazisme et
du communisme n'aurait pas été acceptée
l'occident dans les années 1950 parce
qu'ils s'embrassent et sur les baies et
qui escortait le convoi vers le no1
parler aux français le temps dans
l'escadron
rantigny million de journaux
britanniques de temps de guerre exprimé
admiration pour l'esprit de sacrifice
des défenseurs de stalingrad
mais la piscine d'identifier le fascisme
et terry dans le communisme politique ne
date pas de l'époque de la guerre froide
le débat sur histoire qui continue
aujourd'hui a été ouverte
l'historien marginalement à nantes qui a
choqué à l'époque devenant un enfant
terrible de la politologie occidentales
parce que à l'époque après la guerre
pendant la guerre froide avec langage
très agressive
jamais une politique nommée l'identité
entre le communisme et le nazisme
c'étaient les entités comme le font
aujourd'hui
nous nous avons une lutte nouvelle lutte
des idées des idées il vient logique pas
les idées basées sur le fait n'est sur
les faits et les documents pour nous ces
tragédies parce que pour nous la guerre
patriotique sera a toujours la grande
guerre patriotique
justement le le débat de sur l'histoire
le débat historique que vous avez évoqué
comment ils affectent aujourd'hui la
politique internationale
c'est la politique internationale
d'aujourd'hui c'est les tentatives de
justifier l'arrêt distribution du monde
changer la configuration géopolitique de
voix de monde et de l'euro qui affecte
le débat
après l'effondrement de l'urss le combat
contre l'empiré du mal
querrey idiot logique du totalitarisme
et de la démocratie étaient les
instruments nécessaires aux camoufler
justifie la rétribution
du monde et une nouvelle configuration
et subordination de l'europe à commencer
par l'amérique et le teint et ils
doivent présenter l'urss qu'on le même
monstre totalitaire l'allemagne
hitlérienne et le système précédente
ce précédent contre résultats des
ambitions de fait ce monstre les
lionceaux it is
mais ce paradigme résolu le problème lui
réussissent s'est vu retirer rainures
d'avoir été le combattant principales
villes fascisme et doit perdre tous les
résultats deux victoires le fascisme ubi
n'a pas été réhabilité mais l'occident
ont été plus responsables et celui
naturellement à exiger impérativement la
révision de tous les jugements portés
sur la politique loin d'y aller demander
donc des nouveaux paradigmes sauf ce
dernier améliorer c'est ce responsable
de ce conflit est que les victoires des
serait père victoire mais une défaite
la guerre aurait été menée non pour le
droit des nations à l'existence pour que
les russes restent le ruz
les français restent les français les
boulonnais restent les polonais avec le
droit de choisir son avenir ni pour la
sauvegarde depuis peu dans l'histoire
mondiale
mais pour la demo précis américaine leur
s'est fait déclarer que les mots sont
plutôt les terres comme l'allemagne
nazie elle ne portait pas la démocratie
et pour ça notre pays n'a pas le droit
d'être aurait convaincu heures du
fascisme c'est très clair
on parle toujours dans l'historiographie
modernes n'ont même pas dans toute la
liste auprès l'historiographie qu'on ne
faisait ni à l'époque ni pendant la
diapora il était bien connu que la
colonne s'est ouvertement positionner
comme un ennemi de la russie s'est
catégoriquement au bout
et à toute coalition contre l'allemand
proposée par l'union soviétique à ses
partenaires l'angleterre et la france
mais à un bretteur était déjà de la
politique européen à l'époque et mais
les dirigeants occidentaux connaissez
bien à l'époque ce que c'était l'époque
qui avait provoqué favoriser leur bière
lui aurait cessé les autres étaient
parfaitement informés que hitler est
fixée au 1er septembre 1939 la dette de
l'état contre la colonne dans
l'opération ves
déjà 10 avril 1939 et le 17 avril le rsa
proposé de nouveau au grand bretagne et
la france une autre voie une approche
générale qui était repoussée par les
reçus d'impôt est rejeté par les pays
bas mais cette accusation doit libérer
les pays occidentaux de toute
responsabilité quant à l'heure en tant
qu un munich
pierre licenciés it leur agression dans
l'est de l'europe hier l'annexion de
l'autriche qui marque il est le
véritable début des camps qui est la
sienne et la fin de ce statu quo
territoriales c'est la stratégie
dominique à defacto paralyser toute
configuration alternative de résistance
pour les lionceaux mythique c'est cela
ne signifie privé et le principe de
toute initiative l'impasse de politique
un culte de cinq joueurs politique c'est
pourquoi munich a été le point de départ
de tous les événements ultérieurs
mais juste après les
signature des accords de munich des
déclarations de non agression mutuelle
ont été signés entre la grande bretagne
et l'allemagne et la france
maintenant avant le traité de non
agression entendu eu de cesse l'helmand
cela faisait donc politiquement
impossible pour les victimes de
l'expansion future de résister mais elle
a également empêché les recettes de
prendre les mesures concrètes pour
contrer la blessure par leur c'est ce
serait seul avec lui et c'est exactement
que le ministre britannique des affaires
étrangères a les facs et turquie a
déclaré à maintes reprises au parlement
d'aller presse dans ce livre ce marché
lui les archives je peux citer il est
impossible de dire si le pacte était
plus dégoûtant pour le thriller où
staline et philippe ce whisky church
tous deux étaient conscients qu'il ne
pouvait s'agir que d'une mesure
temporaire dictée par les circonstances
et après il ajoute le fait qu'un tel
accord soit devenu possible marc toute
la profondeur de l'échec de la politique
et de la diplomatie britannique et
français et 30e à la politique de moscou
il ajoute si sa politique était
froidement calculée et l'été très
réaliste a à l'époque personne ne
percevez le pacte molotov ribbentrop
comme quelque chose inattendue et des
justifié à l'époque on convient si bien
que dans le cas d'agression contre
l'union soviétique la pologne serait
l'aï eu il tenir dès janvier 1939 b
ministre polonais des affaires des
plongeurs proclamé je suis une unité
totale de
j'irai avec l'allemagne dans les
rapports avec l'union soviétique et le
service secrètes ont découvert que la
pologne s'était déclarée prête à
soutenir hitler dans la guerre si faire
se tenait ses visées sur le plein et
l'accès de la mer noire
je veux donner notre seulement mais il y
a quinze ans dans le pee lieu de canton
pareil ce n'est pas par hasard dans les
pages du principal journal polonais
rzeczpospolita le 20 à 8 septembre 2005
mr lien paris a regretté que la pologne
et moi je ne venais pas réussi à
s'entendre avec hitler et ne soit pas
devenue nationale et un temps comme on
souligné si cela avait été fait les
jeunes héros polonais aurait pris avec
hitler le défilé de la syrah les membres
victorieuse sur la place rouge
imaginez-vous cet article seulement été
publiée dans le journal principal de
l'apollonide seulement il y à gaza ce
pacte était le résultat des chèques au
cours des tous les tentatives avoir une
configuration défensive commune ensemble
avec des partenaires l'angleterre la
france et aux propriétés pays baltes
sans cette configuration est avec
déclaration de non agression entre
britanniques et de la france et
l'allemagne nazie ce qui reste et c'est
à voir ce pacte pour assembler les
forces pour la future agression de
l'etna maintenant pour revenir
l'actualité au début de l'année le
président russe vladimir poutine a
promis de fermer la bouche de tous ceux
qui tentent de réécrire l'histoire
alors comment mettre en perspective
cette déclaration avec la russie
d'aujourd'hui est pourquoi pour les
autorités russes il ne paraît pas
acceptable de débattre sur la seconde
guerre mondiale on accepte les débats
basé sur les flux et les documents mais
on n'accepte pas les insultes
cette expression de notre président
était naturellement dur mais juste parce
que y notre président a exprimé la
profonde indignation et la colère le
tout notre peuple par les insultes
envers notre passé on n'accepte pas les
insultes vers la nation qui a sacrifié
la 7 millions d'ebit pour que les russes
et les autres nations rester dans
l'histoire pour nous la gears toujours
restée grande et patriotique
la victoire s'est tu ne fais de base
profonde pour notre conscience nationale
n'est disponible
quand on évoque la guerre patriotique
une guerre contre les étrangers venus
conquérir et à servir les discussions
pour savoir si l'état était beau ou
mauvais sont déplacés ce n'est pas
l'état qui était menacé par des germes
orthez
mais la patrie et sans autre exploit il
y aura eu ni démocratie ni union
européenne en europe mais ont
naturellement nous n'oublierons jamais
les héros de la résistance dans tous les
pays bien que nous sachions que beaucoup
plus des européens ont servi dans
l'armée prévient que ceux qui sont dans
les cachots de gestapo
mais je veux féliciter tous les france
avec la grande victoire et lorsque était
d'honorer leur passé je pense à
l'escadron 11h45 les euros français
lutter avec les russes ensemble pas pour
la démocratie au communisme
on ne pensait de ce pas de ça mais pour
l'heure douce france et les mémoires de
cette fraternité dans va rester dans
notre coeur bien si nous attendons
beaucoup du nez des choses celle
comprise et bien tu as dit dans la
presse occidentale et nous aurons je
pense de l'avenir
mais l'énergie pour votre avenir commune
nous avons si nous unissons nos forces
par sa à nouveau défi et pas nous
séparons comme avant les guerres
madame nord jusqu'à merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci à vous merci de nous avoir suivis
bien entendu merci à notre invité et je
vous dis à très vite sur arte france
[Musique]